our views about vaccines have become
blurred by
politics and anxiety by questions over
supply and safety
today the astrazeneca jab was once again
approved for use by europe's medical
regulator
which said the benefits outweigh any
potential link to a very rare type of
blood clot
its benefits in protecting people from
covet 19
with the associated risks of death and
hospitalization
outweigh the possible risks the
committee
also concluded that the vaccine is not
associated with an increase in the
overall risk of thromboembolic events or
blood clots
but despite this announcement on
continental europe the reputation of the
astrazeneca vaccine has been
bruised by questions over its efficacy
at this center in paris they're trying
to accelerate the vaccination process
amid a blend of
cynicism and skepticism
muriel's here she cheerfully took the
astrazeneca jab a few days ago
but she says that has led to a family
row i have a
twin who was supposed to come with me to
have
the first vaccine of astrazeneca
and he said i don't want to have it i
won't
fight her because astrazeneca is
it's not clean the european union
remains furious that it hasn't received
the doses of astrazeneca that it was
promised and ordered
today it started legal action against
the company
well there are plenty of theories to
explain europe's
sluggish vaccine rollout you can blame
bureaucracy
or top-heavy politics a rigid adherence
to the
two-dose plan but there are others who
say this is down to a supply chain
that europe by contrast to the uk or the
us has not done a good enough job
of securing the doses it needs
and that is a sentiment echo by one of
the city's leading public health experts
who told me he's frustrated by a lack of
vaccines
we don't have the dose of the vaccine
and also because it's the
the proudness of friends you know the
brother of friends
we see the uk the the us israel
and trying to get out the crisis and we
are still blocked
the vaccines are the solution to this
pandemic but we're not there yet
and europe trails the uk tonight
confronted by
a third wave of infections france
announced
it is tightening its lock down rules
again
adam parsons sky news paris